yeah do you start to get like
why didn't you why have you had better
luck than some of these guys
I kind of reeled it in bro you mean you
mean why am I still alive yeah is that
what you're asking me yeah I didn't want
to say it like no that's cool it's cool
I think honestly
if we stayed up for three four nights in
a row partying I would still go work out
right nobody else would I still go train
I would still eat good I was the trading
prayers and vitamins I was actually
doing that you know praying that I
wouldn't die he didn't provide him it's
still a prayer yeah yeah but but the
vitamins are Percocets that's awesome
yeah whatever you know maybe a couple
more but uh
I drove a car into an invisible driveway
yeah yeah
that was one of the drugs of choice for
the wrestlers yeah it was very dangerous
for them because it would shut people's
throat down my buddy Richard died he
choked on some chicken that he didn't
even know he was eating and yeah
um but he took some of those muscle
relaxants they relax your throat so much
your it doesn't pull the food down a lot
of people choke today yeah there are a
lot of guys who get the Soma shakes I
don't know if you ever saw that but
that's a little scary
God it sounds like a Tick-Tock Trend
almost it's just like somebody beating
it just and they can't stop or they'll
be walking and they freeze and they I
mean I've seen it happen so many times
when you're eating 10 20 of them at a
time you know
but and people were taking that much
pain pills to feel okay huh oh yeah oh
yeah
and uh you know it for me I would always
um
I never went down that road yeah you
know if they're if you're supposed to
take one or two that would be it I never
went down that road five or ten I never
did that you know you didn't have
addiction it doesn't sound like really
no I and you know when it came to weed
or this and that and the other I could
quit not do it for three four five years
it wouldn't matter yeah you know so it's
like
but you know I just think because I was
real consistent with the training and
actually trying to eat good in between
all the craziness or the drinking and
raising hell I kind of like stayed on
track where I would see these guys
defect for weeks and not go to the gym
and just drink constantly and just not
eat and not sleep and I just I can't
handle it man I had to be the lead dog
man right I still had to be the main
event where they could get be on the
match underneath me and be slacking
right I had I had to blow them yeah to
deliver you know I didn't want anybody
stealing my spot because they were all
trying you know every night yeah I guess
it's strange because your teammates but
at the same time they're low-key trying
to take your throne yeah yeah
well done banana people got hurt they'd
be more than happy to replace me when
you look at a lot of guys have you know
you're in you seem really healthy you
know do you feel healthier than uh I
mean a lot of guys in your line of work
haven't had the
a lot of the same blessings of Health
I mean I know you got a pretty bad spine
you know
um what's bad on you like where's your
health at kind of now
well I think internally I'm healthy it's
just I abuse my body so bad you know
um
the last 10 or 12 years I've had like 25
surgeries you know it's kind of weird
because when I went to do Rocky 3 when
my mother was still alive if you would
come to my house
she'd go Yo T come over here first thing
I want to do is measure you you know oh
yeah and that's what she did to me
before I went to do the Rocky movie I
was like 335 pounds I was six foot seven
on the nose well then right before my
mother died a few years back
she wanted to measure me I was six four
and a half you know between the 10 back
surgeries yeah and the two knee
Replacements and the two hip
replacements and the abdominal stuff and
the shoulders and all the surgeries I've
had you know and plus you get older you
shrink up a little bit Yeah you get a
little bit um so yeah I mean other than
you know like when I'm with Skye and
we're walking I lean on her so it looks
like we're in high school I'm like hey
baby I'm really just kind of like
hanging on you know for the ride or if
I'm not with her I can pretty much walk
I'm home from here to that door but if
it gets too far than that I got like a
walking stick which is embarrassing and
hell is helping me this guy says embrace
it you're a warrior I said you're right
baby you're right I am a warrior you
know it's a way to look at it yeah so
I'm trying to adapt but
um you know we're going in Monday uh
tomorrow morning for another monogram
you know because I'm having some more
issues with my back and they're going to
see if the disc is pushed in the spine
above the hardware
and if it is then they want to go from
the middle of my backup to my neck but
if the disc isn't pushing on the spinal
cord then they said we don't want to cut
on you anymore and there's because my
left hip is like 25 or 26 years old they
think there might be a problem there but
we're gonna find out yeah but it's all
from that damn fake wrestling basins
nobody told me it was fake
um the only thing that I really dug
was you know being in the ring because
when I was in the ring
you know I was real present
you know I didn't think about anything
else you know Ex-Wives ex-girlfriends
kids business problems money problems
three or four guys that wanted to kill
me in the back I didn't think about
anything you know when I was in the ring
I was completely in the moment yeah you
know and when I the one the one thing
that really worked for me was once I
clicked
I was not Terry belayer when I went to
that ring I was Hulk Hogan brother and I
believed it I mean I believed when I was
in there I wasn't afraid of anybody or
anything and I just that was my attitude
you know because if I didn't believe it
you're not going to get them to believe
that they're watching I believed it so I
was so dialed into that character man I
lived through that thing and it got me
through a lot of craziness you know it
helped a lot yeah was there a part where
it started to like where where did it
start to because everything I noticed
like there's a there's a part where it's
fun it's beginning and then it becomes
work you know yeah did it start to feel
like that at a certain point I mean even
if you're a hero to the world it's still
yeah I hate it yeah I hated it I hated
the business because of the traveling
and you know the no sleep you have to
make a choice between
eating sleeping or working out so the
prior priorities were working out first
yeah eating and the sleep was the third
priority
so like if we wrestled in Madison Square
Garden tonight
you know and all of a sudden we're
supposed to fly to St Louis
short flight hour and a half St Louis so
all of a sudden you get the LaGuardia
planes canceled
you know oh my God you can't you know no
doubtsulated it just you spent all days
in the all day in the airport and then
when you landed in St Louis you know do
you go to the hotel first and check in
and waste time or do you go to the gym
first so I'd always go straight to the
gym and work out
and then usually I wouldn't have time to
go to the hotel I usually go to the
arena and I was always on last so I'd
miss room service and food
so that was always a scramble and then
I'd check in the room later at night you
know so it was just a potluck sometimes
the flights would be on time and
sometimes they wouldn't but the
traveling I hated the traveling because
it was I was flying 300 days a year and
it burned you down oh yeah that's brutal
even with stand-up comedy it's like we
get to sometimes you take the overnight
flight because it's the cheapest back
then so sometimes
um when I was living in California we'd
fly so I'd get in at 5 30 you get in at
6 30 in the morning or something so then
they take you straight to radio yeah
right so then you're there for two hours
and then you get back to your hotel now
it's around like 11 A.M but you haven't
slept really so you try to get a few
hours of sleep and then you get up and
want to live it's just that the
traveling Burns people out man yeah you
get off stage last the food call has
already been done oh [__] man I remember
I used to tease John Belushi you know
because we would jump on a blower Friday
night out of uh JFK what do you mean a
blower all night you know oh non-stop
you in an eight ball that guy died in
the coke I think whatever but I I jump
on the the Pan Am you know to go to LA
and we land I'm sorry brother I'll see
you Monday because like he was on the
flight back Monday morning I'd be on it
it seeming like this oh man just beeping
this traveling I said since you got here
Friday night bro I've already been back
to New York and back once yeah I had to
fly back to Russell at the capital
Center I've been back so since you've
been here resting for 48 hours I made
the trip there and back again because no
you didn't I said I swear to God I did
bro you know because you're out of your
mind I said well
so there was a lot of but that's the
part I hated was the traveling how tough
was it because you have a family right
yeah and how tough was it
um I always wondered like to your kids
like to be because you're everybody's
hero like you were like you know you
were a hero to so many people right I
wonder if it's tough for a child to be
like oh how do I make my dad seem like
my hero you know like
how do I make my dad seem like my hero
if he's everybody else's hero you know I
wonder if that's tough for a kid you
know
I'm sure it is you know
um the kids were real aware of who I was
but you know the moment I would come
home bro that Hulk Hogan thing was
dropped really at the front door I
didn't have any pictures of my house of
Me no wrestling crap in the house at all
I didn't want it in my house some of you
guys had belts hanging and pictures of
themselves but would you ever mess up
with everybody like go to your room and
don't come out to the Bell Rings or
something like would you ever like
no no bro I didn't do that but the thing
was you know I was uh I dropped that
whole cooking Persona and the moment I'd
walk in the house I'd take the bandan
off the bald head and I was just Dad or
Terry and I was you know I could switch
gears pretty easy because I just didn't
live that character like oh yeah brother
yeah Bret Hart thinks he's the greatest
wrestler in all this crazy crap that
these guys think you know I just let it
go man it was a job and I was real good
at what I was doing I had to there had
to be a degree of separation from me
because you'll end up killing yourself
to that character I mean all my guys are
dead and I was a ring leader you know I
was a ringleader I was running them all
hard and I'd come to the edge I'd stop
after about four days you guys keep
going I'm out you know
so it's uh I had I had to draw a line in
the sand
so you were able to do that pretty
pretty it was it came naturally for you
it was pretty easy to do I'm really good
at stopping things or starting things
and
and she's been around me a little while
now but just beautiful
I mean you're handsome
but she's better
okay you just hold your horses back all
right and the same brother same brother
yeah but with that baby I got me a whole
new family too so I'm good
nice congratulations what were you
talking about
again
don't look again bro I'm over here
brother yeah cool we're good now
um yeah there's a lot of guys that have
passed away did you go to some of the
guys funerals yeah yeah I quit doing
funerals and weddings because
I walked in on so many hotel rooms where
the guys were passed away you know and
oh over the years just yeah yeah I mean
if you I don't know the numbers now but
you could probably Google one of you
guys could tell you right away but you
know with baseball let's say over the
last 20 years you've already got 20 guys
died or basketball 20 maybe it's 30 or
40. I don't know you know hockey maybe
10 15 20. wrestling 350. yeah I mean
everybody's dead
yeah you know I got a retail store right
down in Clearwater Beach and you know we
sell pictures and posters and I okay
that okay there's six guys in the
picture
I'm the only one still alive it's freaky
man I'm sure you know especially because
my mom and dad are dead my brother's
dead All My Friends Are Dead so kind of
like the mortality thing can get to you
after a while so when you ask you how
how my health is I'm cool
you know with all the backs I mean you
can have one back surgery and end up in
a wheelchair I've had 10. you know and
so I'm
very blessed very lucky bro you know and
and just uh
like I said I'm either all the way in or
I'm all the way up if we're gonna party
bro we're gonna party yeah if I'm gonna
go straight I'm gonna go straight you
know and right now I'm on the straight
run yeah no alcohol no actually I did
take two Tylenols I was hurting so bad
today but I I didn't take tylenol's
Advil or leave for for months now and I
haven't
drank since January 1st but when I go
nice congrats when I go the other way
you're not swear it gets ugly hope you
enjoyed that video and you can watch
another and you can watch this one you
can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one